the universe
is a fascinating place it contains
billions of
all sorts of stars tiny dwarves and
enormous supergiants
dim and bright ordinary and bizarre
stars
all of them are interconnected by
invisible gravitational filaments
thus forming galaxies and star clusters
galaxies in their turn are quite busy
with their own amazing stuff
they form evolve and merge
theirs is a complex and well-regulated
internal structure
predefined by fundamental laws of nature
our galaxy has its neighbors too
today we have picked out the most
outstanding ones to talk about
[Music]
cosmo the first in outer space
the exact number of galaxies in the
universe is not known for certain yet
it is supposedly well over several
hundred billion
galaxies may be of all sorts of
different shapes
as for the main varieties they include
elliptical
spiral lenticular and irregular galaxies
there are subcategories for these as
well the milky way for example
is a barred spiral galaxy
since any galaxy consists of a great
number of stars
these objects masses may reach
incredible values
the mass of the dwarf galaxy segway 2
for example
is just 550 thousand times that of the
sun
as for the supergiant elliptical galaxy
ic 1101
it is 1700 times heavier than the milky
way
together with its immediate neighbours
our galaxy comprises what is known as
the local group
it includes over 50 galaxies three of
which are quite large in comparison to
the others
these are the milky way the andromeda
galaxy and the triangulum galaxy
the diameter of the local group measures
approximately 10 million light years
and its mass is about 3 trillion times
that of the sun
together with a few other galaxy
clusters of more modest dimensions
the local group in its turn comprises
the local sheet
a flat cloud with a diameter measuring
approximately 23 million light years
it is about 5 million light years thick
the local sheet forms part of the virgo
supercluster
a vast element of the large scale
structure of the universe
the local group is conditionally divided
into four parts
the first one is the subgroup of the
milky way
comprised of our galaxy and its
satellites which may be either dwarf
galaxies
or star clusters the milky way is the
second largest galaxy in the cluster
according to today's estimates it
contains 200 to
400 billion stars as well as from 25 to
100 billion brown dwarfs
our galaxy has a spiral structure and
appears to be a disc with a diameter
measuring about 200
000 light years at the same time its
thickness
is just around a thousand light years
still
there is a bulge at the center of the
disc with a diameter of around 27 000
light years
a supermassive black hole with a mass of
as much as 4.3 million times that of the
sun
is supposedly concealed inside the bulge
a smaller black hole is said to be
orbiting it whose mass is anything from
one to ten thousand
times that of the sun it is posited that
it is dark matter that accounts for most
of the mass of the milky way
which is why it is impossible to
estimate it at this point
according to the latest estimates
however the mass of our galaxy is
approximately 1.5
trillion times that of the sun
going slightly further from the milky
way we can observe its 31 satellites
these are mostly irregular shaped dwarf
galaxies
they get so twisted and bent in every
which way on account of the
gravitational influence of their massive
neighbor
our closest satellite is the dwarf
galaxy cma dwarf
which can be found in the canis major
constellation
it lies 25 000 light years away from the
earth
and 42 000 light years from the center
of our galaxy
appearing like an elongated ellipsis
this dwarf galaxy contains
supposedly around 1 billion stars most
of which
are red giants due to the gravitational
influence exerted by the milky way
the canis major galaxy has almost broken
apart
tidal forces had the following
disrupting effect
the stars torn out from the galaxy came
to form the so-called monocerous ring
an elaborate ring-shaped structure that
traps around the milky
way unfortunately observation of cma
dwarf is greatly thwarted by gas
and dust clouds floating between the
galaxy and our earth
the largest satellite of the milky way
and the fourth largest galaxy in the
local group
is the large magellanic cloud it is
located as far as about 163
000 light years containing approximately
30 billion stars
it has a diameter of just seven times as
little as that of our galaxy
at the same time the clouds mass is 300
times
as little as that of the milky way the
explanation for such a stark
contrast is this the large magellanic
cloud
does not happen to contain a
supermassive black hole in the center
besides there are great amounts of dark
matter in the milky way's galactic halo
the large magellanic cloud is an sbm
type
which is in between dwarf spiral and
irregular galaxies
even though the gravitational influence
exerted over it by its massive neighbors
has as well as erased almost all traces
of its former spiral structure
the bar in the center remains to be
clearly distinguishable
there are a few especially notable
objects located in the large magellanic
cloud
for example the star r136a1
lying 000 165.000 years away
is the heaviest star ever detected
this blue supergiant's mass is 315 times
that of the sun
and its surface temperature is as
scorching as over 40 000
kelvin the luminosity of r136a1
is 8.7 million times that of the sun
the large magellanic cloud is also home
to one of the largest stars in the
investigated parts of the universe
the diameter of the red giant woh g64
is over one and a half thousand that of
the sun
this is just 25 percent less than the
diameter of the largest supergiant
ever detected stevenson 2-18
according to today's accepted concepts
of stellar evolution
woh g64 is currently in the final stage
of its life
and is expected to go supernova at any
moment in the next several thousand
years when speaking about the milky way
subgrip
of course we can't but mention the virgo
stellar stream
occupying approximately five percent of
the entire sky
it appears as an exceptionally scattered
and dim flow of several hundred thousand
stars
on the outskirts of our galaxy according
to the overwhelming majority of
scientists
the virgo stellar stream is remnants of
a dwarf spherical galaxy
that has at some point almost completely
been swallowed up by the milky way
moving yet further we will soon
encounter the galaxy known as andromeda
or the andromeda nebula together with
its satellites
it forms part of the local group
referred to as the andromeda subgrip
the galaxy lies as far as around 800
kilopasc
or two and a half million light years we
transit the status of our closest
neighboring galaxy
which isn't a dwarf one
the diameter of the andromeda nebula
measures approximately 220
000 light years which is slightly more
than that of the milky way
with its star count of around a trillion
there are three to five
times as many of them in it as there are
in our galaxy
interestingly the masses of the two
galaxies are more or less the same
at around one and a half trillion solar
masses
the point is that the stars forming the
andromeda nebula
are an average elder and lighter than
those of the milky way
andromeda is one of our closest
neighbors appearing as an elongated
light spot
it is also one of the few galaxies
visible to the naked eye
interestingly its angular diameter is
six times that of the moon
the andromeda nebula is a spiral galaxy
with two clearly defined arms
it is peculiar for its binary core
when we observe it through a telescope
we notice two clearly seen
star clusters in the center of the
galaxy with a distance between them
around
five light years according to one of
proposed
theories at some point andromeda
swallowed up another galaxy
capturing its core another supposition
has it that there is
after all just one core with some part
of it obscured by a dust cloud
it is estimated that the overall mass of
the central part of this galaxy is over
140 million solar masses
there are approximately 400 globular
clusters in the andromeda nebula
which is about two to three times as
many as the rye in the milky way
this means that it probably swallowed up
quite a few dwarf galaxies in the past
and the clusters it contains now
are the remnants of their cores
andromeda has around
30 satellites the ones that stand out
are dwarf spiral galaxies
designations m32 and m110
some theories suggest that m32 round the
andromeda nebula
several billion years ago leaving a
gargantuan hole in its structure
this had a serious effect on m32 as well
with a substantial part of this galaxy
becoming andromeda's galactic halo
the milky way is estimated to collide
with andromeda in around
5 billion years time today it is still
quite impossible to model this
tremendous encounter and its
consequences accurately
but it is bound to be a truly
spectacular sight
the third large representative of the
local group is the triangulum galaxy
it is twice as little as the milky way
in size
and has no confirmed satellites but some
dwarf galaxies of the local
group may well be gravitationally bound
to it
the triangulum galaxy is not likely to
boast a supermassive black hole in its
center
the diameter of the galaxy measures
approximately 50
000 light years the distance between
triangulum and the milky way
is 2.7 to 3 million light years
the galaxy also contains the ngc 604
nebula
which is the largest known area in space
where stars are actively born
the stellar nursery's diameter reaches 1
300 light years around 200
supergiants with a total mass of a
hundred thousand solar masses are
compactly grouped here
these stars are young and hot with their
powerful luminosity
ionizing the gas the star cluster is
enveloped in
this gives the gas a bright glow which
in its turn makes the nebula appear
quite bright
apart from the objects mentioned there
are other ones in the local group
which don't fall into any of the
mentioned subgroups
as a rule these are remote dwarf
galaxies and star clusters not tightly
gravitationally bound to
any of the three large galaxies
the galaxy ic-10 can be singled out here
lying approximately 2.2 million
light-years away from the sun
it is the only galaxy of the local group
where stars are actively born
ic10 is shrouded in a hydrogen outer
envelope
whose radius is much bigger than that of
the galaxy itself
the stellar disk of ic10 meanwhile
rotates in the direction
opposite to that of the outer envelope
with their mind-boggling dimensions of
hundreds of thousands of light-years on
end even the largest galaxies remain
tiny dots in the large-scale
structure of the universe the distances
between them are staggeringly enormous
and even light takes millions of years
to reach the closest of them
nevertheless we can still observe and
study them
there are innumerable riddles lurking in
the cosmos
and mankind keeps solving them one after
another without flagging zest
because every new discovery is just
another step in our cognition
of the universe
[Music]
[Music]
you